humanity is confronted countless crises
and many have led to profound and
sometimes unexpected change it was the
economist Milton Friedman who once said
only a crisis actual or perceived
produces real change but what kind of
change can we expect in the aftermath of
the corona virus pandemic and will it be
change for the better
history may give us some answers by the
sauer of 1349 the Black Death had killed
nearly 50% of the population of England
there was a second wave of the plague in
1361
which killed another 20% a disaster yes
but the plague did something which had
begun to look impossible it stopped the
100 Years War with a series of bloody
conflicts between England and France
there was also a profound labor shortage
because so many people had died which
put those who survived in a stronger
position
eventually the exploitive feudal system
under which peasants swore allegiance to
Lords in exchange for a patch of land
and sun protection and collapse
fast-forward to 1918 and another
devastating wave of disease was sweeping
the world the so called Spanish flu
although it didn't actually come from
Spain spread through crowded troop
transports and munitions factories
towards the end of the First World War
by the end of the pandemic more than 50
million people had died but it did give
rise to a new understanding of
infectious diseases and that spurred the
development of public health systems
across the developed world as scientists
and governments realized that the best
defense against pandemics was at a
societal rather than an individual level
calls for a unified medical service in
the UK date back even earlier but it was
until after the Second World War in 1948
that Britain's National Health Service
was launched according to the NHS is
official historian Charles Webster the
Luftwaffe achieved in much
politicians and planners for at least
two decades we only gave you part of
Milton Friedman's famous quote earlier
he went on to say when that crisis
occurs the actions that are taken depend
on the ideas that are lying around as
well as the launch of free universal
health care in the UK the postwar period
saw the adoption of other radical ideas
that weren't lying around at the time
including the rapid nationalization of
industry and the creation of the modern
welfare state globally institutions such
as the United Nations were set up
determined to prevent future Wars
through international cooperation and
diplomacy for the aftermath of
coronavirus leave us with similarly
fertile ground in which new ideas might
flourish will it kick-start new ways of
living working traveling or makers think
again about our attitudes to consumption
or our responsibilities to one another
will ideas such as universal basic
income virtual education or even health
care delivered by robots become logical
next steps in a profoundly altered world
or will we pick up where we left off as
if nothing has happened and if there is
to be change who will decide if it's
change for the better after all not all
the ideas lying around will prove to be
the right ones